and get 2 months free.
♫
>> Tucker: TIME NOW FOR
FINAL EXAM WHERE WOULD PIT
TWO HARDENED NEWS
PROFESSIONALS AGAINST ONE
ANOTHER IN A GLADIATOR STYLE
MATCH TO SEE WHO HAS BEEN
PAYING MORE ATTENTION AT
WORK THIS WEEK.
LAST WEEK YOU WILL REMEMBER
THAT AMERICA’S NEWS
HEADQUARTERS LELAND VITTERT
ENDED SHANNON BREAM’S
LEGENDARY NINE EYE MATCH
WINNING STREAK STARTING A
NEW STREAK OF HIS OWN
TONIGHT.
HIS CHALLENGER FOX NEWS
HEADLINE 24/7 REPORTER PRIDE
OF NEW YORK CITY JOIN US
TONIGHT ON SET.
>> NOT EVEN CLOSE TO
NERVOUS.
>> Tucker: I LOVE IT CAR CAR
FEELING CONFIDENT.
>> Tucker: DO YOU KNOW THE
RULES?
>> LET’S REFRESHMENTS.
>> Tucker: HANDS ON BUZZERS,
I’M GOING TO ASK THE
QUESTION.
THE FIRST ONE TO BUZZ IN
GETS TO ANSWER THE QUESTION.
YOU HAVE TO WAIT UNTIL I
FINISH ASKING THE QUESTION
BEFORE YOU BUZZ.
IN EACH CORRECT ANSWER IS
WORTH A POINT.
IF YOU GET IT WRONG, YOU
LOSE A POINT.
BEST OF FIVE WINS.
ARE YOU READY?
>> YES.
>> HERE WE GO.
>> Tucker: QUESTION ONE,
NORTH AND SOUTH KOREA WILL
JOIN FORCES IN THE WINTER
OLYMPICS NEXT MONTH, THE TWO
COUNTRIES HAVE AGREED TO
COME TOGETHER TO CREATE A
SINGLE TEAM FOR WHICH
WOMEN’S SPORT?
CARLEY?
>> FIGURE SKATING.
>> Tucker: FIGURE SKATING,
TO THE TAPE WE GO.
>> WHAT WILL BE A VERY RARE
SIGHT DURING NEXT MONTH’S
WINTER OLYMPICS, NORTH AND
SOUTH KOREA AGREEING TO FORM
A JOINT TEAM AND MARCH UNDER
ONE FLAG.
>> THEY WILL PLAY TOGETHER
TOO IN THE UNITED WOMEN’S
ICE HOCKEY TEAM.
[BUZZER]
>> Tucker: JUDGES HAVE RULED
JUST BECAUSE IT’S ON ICE
SKATES IT’S NOT THE SAME.
>> I THINK WE SHOULD DO A
HALF POINT.
COULD THAT BE A NEW RULE?
>> Tucker: WE HAVE A ROOM
FULL OF ACCOUNTANTS.
AND THEY HAVE SAID
UNFORTUNATELY WE CAN’T COUNT
THAT.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> Tucker: NICE TRY THOUGH.
>> THANK YOU.
>> Tucker: QUESTION TWO.
YOU ARE ABOUT TO SEE THE
IMAGE OF A CAR DANGLING OFF
THE SECOND FLOOR OF A DENTAL
OFFICE.
CRAZY DASH CAM FOOTAGE OF
THAT INCIDENT WENT VIRAL ON
THE INTERNET THIS WEEK.
THE QUESTION IS HOW DID THE
CAR GET THERE?
CARLEY?
>> OKAY A LITTLE BIT OF A
BACK STORY.
THE GUY WAS ARRESTED.
HE RECEIVED A DUI.
HE FLEW OVER THE MEDIAN AND
BECAUSE OF THE TRAJECTORY
ENDED UP IN THE SECOND STORY
OF THAT DENTAL OFFICE.
>> Tucker: WELL, THAT’S
QUITE AN ANSWER.
>> AND WALKED AWAY
UNSCATHED.
>> Tucker: LET’S SEE IF THE
TAPE REFLECTS THAT.
>> SANTA ANA THE CAR HIT
THAT MEDIAN AND WENT
AIRBORNE AND LANDED RIGHT
NEWT SECOND FLOOR OF A
DENTAL OFFICE.
THE CAR, THERE YOU SEE IT,
DANGLING RIGHT OFF THAT.
>> RIGHT WORD MEDIAN.
>> Tucker: AND HE WALKED
AWAY?
>> NOBODY IN THE DENTAL
OFFICE, I BELIEVE AND HE
WAS, OF COURSE, ARRESTED.
>> Tucker: SO YOU ARE BACK
TO EVEN, STATUS QUO, PAR,
ZERO TO ZERO.
QUESTION THREE.
>> GOOD TO KNOW.
>> Tucker: A MEDICAL
BRIEFING A TELEVISED ONE
REVEALED THIS WEEK THAT THE
PRESIDENT IS INDEED HEALTHY.
THAT DIDN’T STOP REPORTERS
FROM FAT SHAMING HIM, NBC
PRODUCER ASKED APPROVE HIS
WEIGHT WITH A VERY STRANGE
REQUEST WHAT WAS IT?
CARLEY?
>> STEP ON A SCALE.
>> Tucker: I DON’T BELIEVE
THAT.
>> LET’S SEE.
>> Tucker: TO THE TAPE.
>> A MEMBER OF MSNBC’S
INVESTIGATIVE UNIT TWEETED
OUT THIS GEM.
SEEING A LOT OF SKEPTICISM
OVER THE IDEA THAT REAL
DONALD TRUMP WEIGHS ONLY
239 POUNDS.
WE STEP ON A SCALE IN PUBLIC
TO PROVE IT?
HE WILL DO THAT WHEN
REPORTERS AND ANCHORS AGREE
TO LIE DETECTOR TESTS BEFORE
OR AFTER THEIR BROADCAST.
>> LIKE A PRIZE MATCH.
>> Tucker: AMAZING.
OKAY.
STEP ON A SCALE.
I WOULD NOT HAVE GUESSED
THAT QUESTION FOUR, THE
QUESTION RISES ON THE SET.
GOOGLE, WHICH IS A LARGE
SEARCH ENGINE COMPANY JUST
RELEASED A NEW APP. THAT HAS
BECOME POPULAR.
THE APP. TAKES YOUR SELFIE,
A PICTURE OF YOU AND
COMPARES IT TO WHAT?
>> PORTRAITS.
YEAH.
SO MUSEUM FAMOUS MUSEUM
PICTURES, PAINTINGS AND
PORTRAITS FOUND IN MUSEUMS.
>> Tucker: THAT’S BIZARRE.
DOES THE TAPE REFLECT
PORTRAITS, FAMOUS PORTRAITS
IN MUSEUMS.
>> YOUR IMAGE COULD ALREADY
RESEMBLE WORKS OF ART IN A
MUSEUM SOMEWHERE.
THIS IS LOCATED IN THE
MUSEUM IN INDONESIA AND IT
IS A VERY FAMOUS PAINTING.
>> FABULOUS.
>> NOT EVEN TRYING.
THIS IS SUCH BS.
I DID MINE ON MY OWN AND
THIS IS WHAT I CAME UP WITH.
SO SAD YOU SORE LONELY AND
NEEDY YOU WILL LET GOOGLE
USE YOUR FACE.
>> I ACTUALLY DID IT THIS
WEEK AND THE PORTRAIT I
RECEIVED THAT RESEMBLES ME
THE MOST I GOT 60% MATCH WAS
THAT OF A BALD MAN.
>> Tucker: LET’S SEE I THINK
WE DID IT, TOO.
LET’S SEE WHAT WE CAME UP
WITH.
>> IS THAT ME?
I DON’T KNOW HOW I FEEL
ABOUT THAT.
>> Tucker: WE ALSO DID
LELAND.
THIS IS THE POET ROBERT
BURNS.
>> THEY DO YOU, TUCKER.
>> ACTUALLY I’M NOT AWARE
YET.
>> HE DOES HAVE VERY NICE
HAIR.
JUST TOOK OUR FOX I.D.
BADGE.
>> FROM THE 90’S.
>> Tucker: LAST QUESTION.
IT’S MULTIPLE CHOICE.
ACTRESS AND COMEDIAN BETTY
WHITE HAD A BIRTHDAY
YESTERDAY.
SHE CREDITS HER LONGEVITY TO
HER LOVE OF HOT DOGS AND
VODKA NATURALLY.
HOW OLD IS BETTY WHITE?
IS SHE 96, 90 OR 86 YEARS
OLD.
>> SHE IS 86 YEARS OLD.
>> Tucker: SHE IS 86 YEARS
OLD SAYS CARLEY TO THE TAPE
WE GO.
>> VERY, VERY HAPPY BIRTHDAY
FOR A VERY GOLDEN GIRL BETTY
WHITE, EVERYBODY.
SHE IS 96 YEARS YOUNG TODAY.
>> DID I GET THAT RIGHT?
[BUZZER]
>> Tucker: NO, I THINK YOU
ARE WRONG.
SHE IS 96.
OFF BY 10 YEARS.
>> NO.
I REMEMBERED THE 6.
>> DOESN’T PREVENT FROM YOU
WINNING 1-0.
THE LOWEST SCORE EVER
RECORDED BUT STILL
IMPRESSIVE SHOWING.
>> CONGRATULATIONS VERY
NICE.
I WILL SAY TO YOU WHAT
SHANNON SAID TO ME IN THE
GREEN ROOM A COUPLE MINUTES
AGO SHE SAID YOU ONLY HAVE 8
MORE CHAMPIONSHIPS TO WIN
BEFORE SHE WILL COME BACK
FOR A CHALLENGE.
>> Tucker: RISING LIKE
LAZARUS.
YOU WIN THE COLD FRONTED
MOUTH BREATHER MUG.
CONGRATULATIONS CARLEY
SHIMKUS.
>> I GET A MUG?
>> Tucker: DO YOU.
DISHWASHER SAFE.